My SQL Kafka riddies, they can't just be any PAD, they need to be the same PAD, that's
stateful sets.
Deployment PADs are interchangeable, random names, replaceable.
Stateful set PADs are sticky, mydb0 is always mydb0.
Same name, same storage, same identity, even across rescheduling.
PADs are created in order, 0, then 1, then 2.
Reveal down in reverse, rolling updates 1 at a time.
This prevents split brain in clustered databases.
Each PAD gets its own persistent volume claim.
Deleting the stateful set does not delete the volumes, your data stays safe.
Stateless workload, use a deployment.
Need stable identity and persistent storage, stateful set.
Databases live here.
Run the docs, Kubernetes, stateful sets.